she was somebody who had gone through
war with me think about it from her
perspective for a second so she met this
guy on the internet four weeks later she
quits her job which she had a good
career starts flying around the
countries I thought I quit to do this
thing with you but now you're doing lots
of things then says I don't think I want
to do this anymore and then at that
point when you're living in a motel with
this dude who says he doesn't want to be
with you you then fly to Hawaii and
still make him money when my world was
crumbling and Layla stood tall and she
crushed it she broke and set the record
to this day for a single launch location
it's kind of like you can say you're
loyal but until you have the opportunity
to cheat you are in anything you need
evidence to claim the trait lay let's
have his nails she was somebody that I
would go to war with